As I mentioned last
Friday, there is one more topic
that I want to cover.
And that is the
topic of diffusion.
And so today, I'm going to
talk about diffusion, which
will be in the context of
what diffusion depends on
and how do we describe it.
And in particular,
there's two laws,
Fick's first law and
Fick's second law,
that I want to talk about.
And I want to talk
about how this
looks in the context of
some of the chemistry
that we've learned, some of
the things that we've learned.
So diffusion, this is
kind of a standard picture
people show for diffusion,
although really, this
is probably mostly convection,
which is the movement.
It's not diffusion.
But diffusion kind of has
taken on this broader meaning.
And so what do we
mean by diffusion?
Well, diffusion comes from
the Latin word diffundere.
And that means to spread out.
But in this class,
we're going to start
by thinking about it as
a particular movement
down a concentration gradient.
And that is what's
happening here.
You see there's a very
concentrated droplet
of dye that you put in there.
And then it's less
concentrated out here.
You probably don't have any.
So the concentration of
the dye out there is zero.
And in here it's very high.
And so it wants to go down
a concentration gradient.
So that's movement down
OK.
How do we describe
this movement?
And it really goes
back to experiments
that Robert Brown did.
And this is the original
paper that he wrote way back
in the early 1800s.
I love the title of this
paper, "A Brief Account
of Microscopical Observations
Made Specifically
in the Months of June, July,
and August 1827 on the Particles
Contained in the
Pollen and Plants
and on the General Existence
of Active Molecules in Organic
and Inorganic Bodies."
What a nice, detailed title.
That was Brown.
So he started with pollen.
And he looked at it.
And it looked like this.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Oh, that's very loud.
There wasn't
supposed to be music.
So that's what he saw, except
this isn't what he saw.
This is what Koshu Endo
randomly posted online
and I'm showing you.
But if you look at
pollen in a microscope,
and you're Robert Brown
back in the early 1800s,
you'd see this.
So he thought, aha,
OK, there's life.
This is must have
to do with biology.
And things are alive.
And so they move.
And it must be
something like that.
And so he put other things in.
And they did the same
thing, they jiggled around.
And then he said,
well, OK, what about
if I put something that was once
alive but is not alive anymore.
And it did the same thing.
He said, OK, wait a second.
Maybe there's something to do
with having ever been alive,
the spirit of the particles.
And he said, OK, the
ultimate spirit, I'm
going to break some glass--
which is what he
did, I love that.
I like breaking glass too.
And so he broke the glass.
And he took little
pieces of glass
and put it under his microscope.
They did the same thing.
They all did the same thing.
So they were really perplexed.
What was going on?
This is the microscopic basis.
This is now called
Brownian motion.
It's random motion due to
thermal energy and collisions.
And it's the connection of
this microscopic random motion
due to thermal energy and
macroscopic observables that
led to a big advance in our
understanding of diffusion.
And so the question of
how far took 80 years.
So one of the first
questions, you
say, how far do these things go.
How far are they going?
They're randomly moving around.
I got that.
I see it in the microscope.
How far do they go?
So how far?
Well, that was a
question that you
can answer if you can get the
mean squared displacement.
I don't know.
I say tomato.
And so displacement, it's OK,
mean squared displacement.
And it really came
from Einstein in 1905.
Actually, this is what Einstein
did for his dissertation,
his Ph.D. work
was on this topic.
It was on
understanding how to go
from these kind of microscopic
random fluctuations
to some macroscopic observables.
And so, the mean squared
displacement, well,
that's just the average of some
measurement of some distance
the particles go.
So if you go back to
the dye, there it is.
But now it's in atom
form or molecule form.
And it's diffusing
around, diffusing around.
And OK, you say, well,
how far did it go.
That would be the circle.
And that's something that
Einstein tackled in his Ph.D.
and found that the mean
squared displacement is--
well, let's just say it's equal
to 6 times some constant times
time.
This is in three dimensions.
If you're in two
dimensions, it's 4.
If you're in one
dimension, it's 2.
But the main point isn't that.
The main point is that the
mean squared displacement
is a function of some
constant times time.
And so if you just
wait long enough
and you know this
constant, then you
can figure out how
far things diffuse.
That was pretty cool.
But you see, now,
what we're going
to be more interested in
in this class is not how
far but how fast.
We're interested in how fast.
And again, these are questions
that Brown couldn't answer.
Brown observed these things
and wrote about them.
And that's why it's
called Brownian motion.
But it was later that
people said, well,
let's try to think about
how to write this down
and come up with
theories that explain it.
And so for how fast,
now we have the flux.
So we have the flux or
the diffusion flux J.
And what we want is a way
of describing how much.
So it's an amount of
something, the amount
of the substance per area.
You're going to normalize it.
So you say, I'm going
to take this sheet.
And I'm going to
say, how much of it
is crossing this
sheet area per time.
So amount of a substance per
area per time, that's the flux.
So it could be grams.
The amount could be grams,
mass, kilograms, micrograms,
nanograms.
It could be number
of atoms, moles.
That's also an amount, moles.
So we just say
amount, it's general.
Grams, moles, et cetera,
n number of atoms.
That's what moles tells us.
Grams, et cetera--
The time could also be--
well, the area could
be centimeter squared,
meters squared.
That's an area.
And then the time
is usually seconds.
Usually, it doesn't have to be.
And so this is what
Fick's law gives us.
So this was first established.
How do you get a
dependence of this flux?
And again, we've got
this constant in there.
And Fick's first law
is all about that.
Fick's first law says that
this flux is proportional to--
and I'm just going to write
it like this for now--
concentration gradient.
So that's C divided
by the change in X. C
is concentration here.
We'll draw an arrow.
Concentration is C.
Now, we could use brackets.
Bracket A, concentration
of A, mass per liter,
something like that.
I'll use the letter C,
delta C over delta X.
So that's the
concentration gradient.
Oh, by the way
this wasn't as far.
It didn't take as
long as Einstein.
But this was 1855.
OK, good.
So Fick came along
maybe 30 years later.
And he said, well, I want to
know how fast things are going.
I want to understand
how to describe
the flux of these
randomly moving things.
And I notice that it depends on
the concentration difference.
And in particular, I like it
when diffusion is positive.
So J is equal to
minus D times dc/dx.
And that is Fick's first law.
Gesundheit.
And D is a constant.
D is this constant again.
So D is the diffusion constant.
We'll talk about this,
diffusion constant.
There's the
concentration gradient.
And we got a minus sign.
Notice, movement down a
concentration gradient.
But if I didn't
have a minus sign,
then I wouldn't have
a positive flux.
Then the droplet
wouldn't spread out.
That wouldn't be good.
So we're going from
high concentration
to low concentration.
When I've got a bigger
change in the concentration,
I've got faster diffusion.
That's what Fick's
first law tells us.
OK, good.
Very importantly, Fick's first
law means it's steady state.
Notice, there is no t here.
There's no time.
For that, we have to
wait for the second law.
So steady state
diffusion, and that
means not a function of time.
The kinds of problems where
Fick's first law matters is--
and I know some of you have
probably seen Fick's first law.
I get that.
But in a little bit, we're
going to connect it to crystals.
But the kind of diffusion
where the first floor matters
is the kind where you're
holding concentrations equal.
Let's say you're holding
a concentration gradient,
and it's not changing.
And so you're
wondering, well, if I
hold a concentration at one
thing here and at another thing
here, how fast do
things diffuse.
That's what Fick's law tells us.
And so let's do an example.
Here's my example.
I found these gloves, because
I was looking for copolymers.
Here's a copolymer that doesn't
have the nitrile groups.
Remember, the nitrile
groups last Friday
that were so important when we
were doing our polymer design.
This doesn't have it.
This is butyl rubber.
OK, fine.
So there's the copolymer.
It's copolymerized
with these two groups.
But now, it's got those
groups, because it gave me
the right flexibility and
some of the other factors
that I want in the glove.
But is it strong
enough chemically?
And that's a very
important question.
We talked about this last Friday
that these chemical groups
change the mechanical
properties.
They also use the
chemical resilience.
And so here I have it.
I have a toxin.
This is why we wear
gloves, because we
don't want to get methyl
chloride into our skin.
Methyl chloride is toxic
at 50 parts per million.
Keep it out.
Be very careful.
So I don't know.
I look up online and say,
well, OK, butyl rubber.
These feel comfortable.
But how are they?
OK, with methyl chloride, which
is a toxin, it's a molecule,
it has a diffusion
constant of 1 times 10
to the minus 6 centimeters
squared per second.
The gloves are 0.04
centimeters thick.
And I'm working
with paint remover.
I'm working with paint room.
The concentration
of paint remover
is a gram per centimeter cubed.
Am I safe?
How much am I going
to be exposed to this?
At my skin, I'm
starting out with zero.
What's the flux
through the glove?
Can I stay safe?
Well, first of all, one
thing that we can do
is we can look at--
just to make sure we understand.
So there's the
diffusion constant.
Why does it have those units?
You can see this.
The units of J are an amount--
this is what we already said--
divided by an area times a time.
So if the units of
C are an amount--
OK, I stayed with grams--
over a volume, then you can
see right away that diffusion
must be area over time.
It has to be.
If it's not, then
the units don't work.
I've got concentration
over a length.
This is a 1 D. I'm going
across some membrane
maybe or some area.
This is a membrane, the glove.
And so you can think
about this for yourself.
The units have to
be area over time.
Is it area over time?
Centimeters squared per second.
They were, OK.
So that worked.
Now, another thing is,
before we do the math,
why does this happen anyway?
Why is there diffusion?
And it's actually quite
straightforward to understand,
even when you go all the way
back to Brown's experiments
with pollen.
You say, well, things
are moving randomly.
Why is there now a direction?
How is that possible?
How can there be a direction
if it's all random?
How can there be a
concentration gradient?
And then you can get
that, because if you
have some high concentration--
Let's suppose that this
is a high concentration,
and this is a low concentration.
And you've got the
Brownian stuff going on.
It's all in something.
There's Brownian motion.
Whatever containers these
are, whatever is in whatever,
it's got Brownian motion.
And so that means that,
because it's random,
it's equally likely to go that
way as it is to go that way.
But see, at the
high concentration,
I've got more particles.
You can see that, because I
drew bigger, longer arrows,
so it's obvious, more
particles, because it's
more concentration.
There's just a lot more of them.
So there's more going across.
If I tried to draw a boundary
here or boundaries inside here,
and I look at those as my areas.
There's a high concentration.
There's a lot of
stuff going randomly
back and forth across them.
Down here, you can
do the same thing.
But there's a lower
concentration,
so there's less stuff
going back and forth
across those barriers.
And now I bring them together.
I bring them together.
I bring the methyl chloride
to the glove, to my hand.
Or I bring something with a high
concentration next to something
with a low concentration.
And I keep the concentrations
of the endpoints fixed.
I hold these fixed.
Fick's law tells me
now how this happens.
And you know that if I bring
them together now, well, look,
this was going just a
little bit back and forth.
And this was going a
lot bit back and forth.
And so there's going to be
a net diffusion that way.
Right there at the
edge, you can see it.
More goes to the right
than goes to the left.
And so this starts to
create a diffusion gradient.
That'll create a
diffusion gradient.
So that's why it works.
That's why concentration
gradients cause diffusion.
And Fick's first
law tells us how.
OK, well, if we go
to the question--
so let's see-- so the J--
so now I've got my glove.
And so the J is equal
minus 1.1 times 10
to the minus 6 centimeters
squared per second times--
and this is going to be--
OK, I started with what?
I started with 1 gram
right per centimeter cubed.
And on the skin I've got 0.
So it's going to be time 0 minus
1 gram per centimeter cubed.
And that's going to be
divided by the distance 0.04
centimeters.
And this goes to something
like 2.5 times 10
to the minus 5 grams per
centimeter squared second.
That's the flux.
That's what Fick's law tells us,
because my skin is good enough.
My body is good enough that any
time a toxin, a methyl chloride
molecule touches it,
the skin just takes it
away and poisons me.
But that's important.
It's not good, but
it's important,
because it keeps this
concentration fixed.
Otherwise, this would build up.
And it would be changing.
So you can't use Fick's law.
No.
Fick's law applies when these
two concentrations are fixed,
and there's not a
time dependence.
Instead, there's a rate.
There's a flux that
you're after, J.
And so now you say,
well, can I handle this.
Can I handle this?
Work it out, 50
parts per million.
I should have used the nitrile.
Should have used the
nitrile copolymer.
Go back and make new polymers.
Maybe you need much, much
better chemical resilience,
which might lower this
diffusion constant.
This is serious stuff.
And it's so serious that
I want to talk about eggs.
The rubber glove
stops this toxin.
Well, it slowed it down.
Did it slow down enough?
Use Fick's first law.
But you can make membranes that
are actually very selective.
It's the coolest thing.
You make a membrane
that only allows water
to go through but not salt.
That's a selective membrane.
And that's called
osmosis when you can
allow one fluid to go through.
It's semi-permeable,
permeable to one type of fluid
but not another.
And the egg is such
a great example,
I had to show you this video.
I made this years
ago in another class,
because I wanted to show it.
This is what you
can do with eggs.
They're so cool.
Here's a video.
So you soak them in vinegar.
OK, it's even got
directions and everything.
We don't need any volume.
And there they are.
OK, you soak them in vinegar.
Now, the vinegar dissolves
the calcium carbonate.
You know this.
You've done these reactions.
So there you go.
You soak them in vinegar.
Leave it overnight, I'd
say, is probably best.
Then you peel off the vinegar.
And look, there's a membrane.
The egg has a really
cool membrane.
This isn't cooked.
This is just a raw egg.
But now I add a bunch of syrup.
Now, this is almost pure sugar.
So the concentration
gradient is enormous,
because the liquid
inside the egg
doesn't have any sugar in it.
But outside, the liquid has
huge amounts of sugar in it.
So the water inside the
egg wants to diffuse out.
Eight hours, well,
it's kind of enough.
18 hours, you pick
that membrane up.
It's a really cool
membrane, the egg membrane.
It's a semi-permeable membrane.
And it's hard to see here.
But you see, all the
water is kind of gone.
It's totally deflated
but completely stable,
because the membrane's
that strong.
The water inside has left.
And then if you
get some green dye
and you put it back
into some green water,
then you can make green eggs.
And you can make
green ham that way.
And that's osmosis.
But it's semi permeable.
You've got to give
the credit right.
You got to give the credit
right in these things.
This was years ago
when I thought I
had a career in that direction.
So the egg is just such a
cool membrane to play with.
And I though, most of
us can access an egg.
If you want to
play with a really
cool semi-permeable
membrane, that is cool.
And you really will see
Fick's first law at play.
You will see it, and
you will feel it.
Now, there's one thing
I want to comment
on about all this stuff.
And we are not going to
learn the details of entropy
in this class.
That is really something
for a thermodynamics class.
But I got to just
correct something,
because it's in your textbook,
because a lot of this diffusion
stuff, and in fact
dissolution-- remember we
talked about salt dissolving?
We did whole lectures on
this, the dissolution.
Remember, these all have
to do with the total energy
of the system.
But we really focus in this
class on one part of that,
on one part, which is called
the enthalpy, the bonding,
the potential of the bonding.
But there's a whole other part
that's related to the entropy.
And we're not going to go into
this in detail, like I said.
You won't be tested on this.
But I got to bring it up.
So entropy can be
really important.
Why does something dissolve?
It may be dominated by entropy.
That goes into the
total energy still.
So we still have our happy
place, lower energy better.
But as you learn more about
what that energy entails,
you've got to start including
entropy in the future.
So Averill says, "...for now,
we can state that entropy is
a thermodynamic property of all
substances that is proportional
to their degree disorder."
No!
That's not true.
That is not true.
So I have a question.
So you see this all the time.
Entropy, higher
entropy, more disorder.
My room is messy, it's
got a high entropy.
So which of these
has a higher entropy?
Which one of these has a higher
entropy, and which is lower?
This is a very simple grid.
They've got the
same exact number.
How many think that the
one on the right is--
it's the smoother one, right?
How many think that this is
the lower entropy system?
I've set this up.
I've set this up, because
you know that's not.
But why?
The reason is the real
reason for what entropy.
It is not simply,
because in this-- these
are computerized experiments.
So we told a computer
to pick randomly a place
on a grid a certain number
of times and then fill it in.
But in this case,
you restricted it.
You said, no.
I can't have any two
squares next to each other.
And in this case, you
simply did it randomly.
So this looks smoother.
This looks less disordered.
But this has a higher entropy.
Why?
Because you have fewer options.
And that is what
entropy is about.
Entropy is about the number of
possibilities that you have.
Now, that might look more
disordered, it might not.
But under the hood of
entropy is possibilities.
It's number of states,
of accessible states.
A salt atom in the crystal
has very few possibilities.
If it were a perfect
crystal, one,
it's got to be in the lattice.
But once it goes
into the liquid,
it's got many more
possibilities.
It's those numbers of
states that matter.
That's why its entropy
goes way, way up.
It's the number
of possibilities,
the number of possible states.
OK, good.
That was my aside on entropy.
Now, we talked about
Fick's first law.
We talked about diffusion.
We looked at drops.
And we made sure the gloves we
choose are going to be safe.
What about solids?
Well, things diffuse
around in solids too.
Here's a red atom that
is going to diffuse.
Watch this super
high-tech video.
How does it do it?
A vacancy comes in.
Look at that vacancy, moving
around, moving around, bam!
That atom moved, it
moved, self-diffusion.
It moved.
It's an atom of
the same type that
was able to move in the lattice
because a vacancy diffused
through right.
And so there's the beginning.
And there's the end.
You see it moved
over by one position.
But now we're all thinking.
We're all thinking,
and we're going back
to our days of,
well, OK, hold on.
What really happened?
So here's the
vacancy on one side.
Here, it went over to this side.
There's the atom going through.
So the vacancy moved that way.
The atom moved that way.
But as you know, that atom had
to experience some barrier.
So it had to get
over some activation.
It had to get over
some activation.
And that really helps us
answer a question that
has been burning in our minds
this whole lecture, which is,
what else does flux depend on.
We saw the concentration
gradient thing.
We looked at it in
very simple terms.
We understood it.
But what about D itself?
Well, when you see something
that's an activated process,
there's only one person that
ever comes to mind, right?
First name S, last
name A. And it's
Svante, because you know that
if it's an activated process,
then there's some
pre-exponential factor
times the activation
energy divided by k B T
if it's for a single atom.
Or if it's a mole, you use R.
There's your activation
energy right there.
But so now, we can
start connecting this.
So one thing you know about
that diffusion constant is it
will have a
temperature dependence.
And you also know now that if
you plot the log of it versus 1
over T, you will get that.
Oh, we're back.
We're in our happy
place with this.
It's Svante.
So this is an activated
process for an atom diffusing.
These kind of atoms diffusing
through their own lattice,
remember, these
have high barriers.
This might be kind
of hard to do,
but it's still going to happen.
It's still going to happen.
You might also get
something like this.
And this goes back
to our discussions
of defects in crystals.
You might get an
interstitial diffusion.
So this is diffusion.
This is the topic
that we're covering.
But now we can
relate the equation
that governs diffusion,
the D, to the crystal
and to the chemistry, because
what is the barrier that that
feels when it goes through.
So remember, an interstitial,
like carbon and iron
to make steel.
That would be an interstitial
defect or an interstitial atom
that you've added to the
system, to the iron lattice.
And how does it move?
Well, that's
absolutely critical,
because it tells
you how to make it.
And we'll get to
an example of that.
So if I look now
at these plots--
and these are plots I think I
showed you back when we talked
about interstitial defects.
You can really connect
it to what we've learned.
So just to start, these are
the log diffusion coefficients.
So that's the
diffusion coefficient
that we're talking
about right there.
Versus 1,000 over T-- so it's
1 over T scaled by 1,000.
And these are those beautiful
Svante Arrhenius dependencies.
And these are
experimental measurements.
And look, here's
hydrogen in BCC iron.
Here's hydrogen in FCC iron.
Now, notice, at the
same temperature,
there's a huge difference.
And then, I have FCC
up here, and then I've
got BCC over there.
Why?
Well, those are the stable
phases at those temperatures.
But notice that when they're
at the same temperature,
there's a huge difference.
Why?
Because you know
from the crystal
structure that
there's more room.
So the activation barrier
will be lower in BCC.
Those voids are bigger.
There's more space.
It's not as well packed.
We've covered that.
And look at this.
So there's hydrogen,
it's really small.
There's iron, iron in BCC Fe
compared to hydrogen in BCC Fe.
Look at those
orders of magnitude.
So there's an iron atom
diffusing in its own solid.
And here's hydrogen atoms.
You can see there's
carbon and so forth.
So this is the picture
that comes back.
If we want to think about
diffusion in solids,
we can connect it to the
packing and crystal structures,
because we know that these
atoms, these interstitial atoms
are going to diffuse through
the interstitial space.
What is the interstitial space?
Well here, as just and example,
I showed just BCC and FCC.
Here they are.
Here's is an octahedral site.
This is BCC down here.
So notice, the shaded in atoms
are the lattice sites, BCC,
at the corners
and in the middle.
And now, you see, the red
atom is in the middle.
Gesundheit.
Let's say the red atom was here.
And it's moving to there.
And now it's in the middle.
So it might take that
path as it diffuses.
It's going to find the voids.
Diffusing atoms find the voids.
And so if you have something
that's trying to diffuse,
it's going to want
to find these voids.
This is an octahedral site,
because this is an octahedron.
And you can have one of those
in an FCC crystals as well.
You can have an octahedral side.
So in FCC, you've got
lattice sites in the face
but not in the center.
And so its octahedral
site is here.
You've got tetrahedral sites.
Those are other voids
in the crystals.
We touched on this a little bit
when we talked about defects
in crystals.
But now I want to
relate it to diffusion,
because how a crystal has voids
is critical to D, how something
diffuses in it,
whether that something
is something in
the crystal itself
or something you've added to it.
And how it has voids depends
on the bonding, the chemistry,
and the crystal structure.
So you could answer
questions like this.
These are some just fairly
straightforward questions
that you could answer.
What if I had carbon-- this
is what I just showed you--
in alpha or gamma iron?
Well, so I'll just
write the answer.
It's alpha ion,
because it's an open--
I don't need to calculate stuff.
Which one is BCC,
which one is FCC?
And it's alpha, because
it's an open BCC structure.
And so the diffusion barriers
are going to be lower.
Iron in alpha iron
at 500 or 900?
Well, now I've got a
temperature question.
I know D is going to be
higher, so 900 degrees C
because of influence
of temperature.
Iron or hydrogen in alpha iron.
It's like what we
just talked about.
So this would be particle size.
H is smaller.
These are conceptual questions.
What's the fourth one?
Silicon vacancy in silicon
or helium in silicon.
Well, for a vacancy
to move, you need
those kind of same atoms move.
And if a same moving through
those sites, that's harder.
That's harder than if a small
interstitial like hydrogen
is moving through those voids.
That's why, when
you look at this,
iron is orders and orders
of magnitude slower.
The D is orders and
orders of magnitude
slower than carbon or
hydrogen. And so that's
going to be He, because the
vacancy diffusion is so much
slower.
And then five, Mg,
this is a good one,
because hydrogen in platinum
or hydrogen in magnesium.
Well, magnesium has a
larger atomic radius.
And you look it up.
And you say, they've got the
same close-packed crystal
structures.
But one of them has
a larger radius.
What does that mean?
Well, it says something
about the voids as well.
The voids are
going to be larger.
Remember, this is happening
through the voids.
This is happening
This is how batteries
are engineered.
This is why we have a
revolution in batteries.
So this is a couple
of years old.
There so many great
review articles
on battery technologies.
This is the cathode.
By the way, what is a battery?
Well, a lithium battery
is basically two sponges.
And one of them
is usually carbon.
And when you're
running your battery,
lithium ions are going in.
And the carbon is
so strong and able
to hold those lithium
in and not break down.
So we often use carbon
on the anode side.
And then when we
charge it up, we
push them back over to where?
Where they came from.
That's the cathode, which
is a lithium compound.
But it has to be a material
that can hold lithium
in it, hopefully at
very high concentration,
but also be OK to lose it
and not completely collapse.
And so you've got
lithium ion phosphate,
those are these ones.
You've got manganates.
You've got cobalts,
cobalt oxide materials.
There are so many
battery materials.
They all work the same way.
If it's a lithium
battery, the lithium
is going to leave some crystal
that has lithium in it.
But the crystal has to stay.
So it's like a sponge that
loses something from it
but stays intact.
And that's something
goes over to the anode.
It gets soaked up there.
And you can recharge,
discharge, recharge,
as you're just pushing these
lithiums back and forth.
Oh, but you're pushing
them back and forth.
You are diffusing them.
That's what you're doing.
You are diffusing them
through whatever structure
you're putting them into.
So if it's the
cathode, and you're
trying to get the lithium to
come back in or to go back out,
then you can imagine that the
barriers and the dimensionality
itself are crucial.
What is an activation
energy for a lithium
atom in a given material?
And does it take a 1 D path?
It turns out these can
be extremely efficient.
Look at those.
They're practically
holes, they're
lines in the lithium
ion phosphate.
It's a really nice
cathode material,
because you've got
these channels.
These high conduction
channels, these highways.
But then you say, well,
but maybe I need 3D voids.
Maybe it shouldn't
have channels.
It should have voids, so
it can choose more paths.
Maybe we have planes.
Maybe it's a layered structure
where they have these 2D
planes they can travel through.
What's the best?
Well, it's not
trivial, because it's
one of these, as
usual, constrained
optimization problems, where,
when you make the pathway
faster, you might need
to have more voids where
you'll lose material.
Or maybe you make the
material unstable.
So you want it to have
a really high density.
The lithium diffusion
and a battery material
is related to the charge time.
So here's another paper
from a few years ago.
If you plot materials-- now,
here's the specific power.
And so that's how much
power, watts per weight.
Here's the watt hours.
So that's the energy per weight.
And this is the charge rate.
This is the charge rate.
And notice, so you want it to
be very, very fast-charging.
And these are good materials.
There's the lead-acid battery
that's still in your car.
These are nickel metal
hydrides and so forth,
other technologies.
Here are the lithium
ion batteries.
This is what's in
your cell phone.
Notice something, as I get
up to faster charge rates,
more open voids in material,
I lose energy density.
I go this way.
I don't want to go that way.
I want to go this way.
Constrained optimization,
these are the things.
What goes into
solving these problems
is calculating diffusion
barriers and energy densities
and all the other
things that matter.
But if you want to
target fast charging,
you've got to know the
diffusion barriers.
One of the number one
challenges in battery design
is to keep that high while
continuing to push up that way.
Polymers, you could imagine
that a polymer is slower.
It makes sense, right?
Because it's
harder-- as we talked
about when we talked
about polymers,
it's harder to make
crystalline polymers,
to keep a polymer from
having some amorphous region.
After all, you've got these
100,000-unit long strands
of spaghetti.
So it kind of makes
sense that the diffusion
is going to be
lower in a polymer
than in one of these
crystals, like an olivine,
lithium ion phosphate.
So that makes sense.
But polymers would be great,
because they're lighter.
And they can be flexible.
And so we like polymer
batteries a lot.
We want them for
many applications.
So these are the kinds of
tradeoffs that you think about.
And D is right there in the
center, because none of us
want a battery that
takes two days to charge.
And now we get to the next
part, which I'll just introduce,
which is, now we're going
to think about time.
And I want to set
this problem up.
And then we'll solve it
on Wednesday and then
and then finish.
But I want to set it up,
because the next thing that's
related to diffusion is time.
And I want to give
you an example
of how that's so
important with something
called case hardening.
So if you buy a gear--
and you do buy
gears all the time.
Whether you like it or not or
know it or not, lots of stuff
has gears in it.
And you look at
the gear closely,
it would look different
on the outside.
If you do a
cross-section, most gears
are going to look
different on the outside.
And the reason has to do
with exactly what we just
talked about.
If this is a piece
of iron, pure iron,
it's going to be too soft.
So you're now turning this.
And it's got to have
mechanical integrity.
And so you've got
to make it harder.
But the thing is, if you put
it in and it's pure iron,
it's too soft.
But now if you make it this
really ultra-high strength,
carbon-infused steel,
it gets too brittle.
It gets too brittle.
And so you need a balance.
And one of the ways to balance
the mechanical strength
of something like a gear or
many, many other materials
is to harden just the outside.
That's cold case hardening.
The case, it's the case.
How do you do it?
Well, you get carbon.
Remember, carbon going into
the iron makes it a lot harder,
but it also makes
it more brittle.
So if you made the whole
gear the same amount
of carbon infused in iron,
is going to be too brittle.
If you don't put any on, it's
not mechanically strong enough.
So what you do is you
very, very delicately
expose this piece
of iron to carbon.
You harden it, but
just on the outside.
Now, how does the carbon get in?
Diffusion.
It gets into the material
through diffusion.
So then the question at
your gear-making plant
that you have to know
is, what temperature
and how long should I expose
this gear to how much carbon.
You've got concentration.
You've got temperature.
And you've got time.
And if you know that,
you can actually
process this material in
just the way you want.
And you have to know
those parameters.
And that is Fick's second law.
So these are steel pipes.
And they are going
to be case hardened.
So what's happening?
You've got an iron
with a certain amount
of carbon content.
But now, I need to add
more carbon but just
the right amount to the
exterior of those steel pipes.
How long should I do it?
And that is Fick's second
law, which I'll write down.
So how do we figure that out?
Well, we use the time dependent
version of Fick's law.
And Fick's second law says that
the change in concentration
with time is equal to the
diffusion constant times
the second derivative of the
concentration with position.
That's Fick's second law.
And so this is non-steady
state, which means--
and we're not going
to derive this.
But I do want you to know
that this is the Fick's
second equation and
how you might apply it,
which is why we'll
do a problem with it.
But it's non-steady state.
And that means that
the concentration
that you're going
to get is going
to be a function of
position and time.
It's going to be a
function of both.
So now, I can
answer the question.
Remember before, I had to
keep the concentrations fixed
to apply Fick's first law.
Now I can answer the question.
Well, OK, if I have
certain parameters,
what is the concentration
going to be.
What is the
concentration going to be
at some time and some place?
And that's exactly the
question I have to answer.
How much carbon am I
going to have at what
position in the case hardening?
In what position of
the pipe exterior,
how much carbon am I going
to have at what time?
How long should I
leave it in the oven?
That's the question
I'm trying to answer.
And by the way,
what temperature?
And so the thing that Fick's
second law helps us understand
is, if I start with
some C S that's
the starting concentration, and
I have a starting concentration
C 0, and I expose at the surface
some higher concentration--
remember, before,
I kept these fixed.
And I got a flux.
Now, I'm going to
be able to get this.
So this line here
is time equals 0.
But now I can actually
get this profile.
Time 2, time 3, that's the
position through some surface.
So this is what Fick's
second law tells us.
It tells us these profiles, the
concentration in the material.
And it just simply is a
time-dependent version
of diffusion.
OK, what we're
going to do is we're
going to pick up with this.
We'll do this example
of case hardening.
We'll do a few more
comments on the class.
I'll tell you a little
bit about the final.
And please bring your laptops
on Wednesday for the last 15
minutes.
We'll reserve for you
to do evaluations.